hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about the latest
epic war arc developments in
boku no hero including the fate of some
of our favorite class
1a and 1b students and some important
information that may have just been
revealed
about gigantomachia and how this
specific information
could relate to the truth about
shigaraki
and his new powers the war arc is in
full swing and it has been for quite a
while
but something big is definitely coming
quite literally so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the boku no hero
content on this channel and you want to
see more please leave a like to let me
know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or you
just haven't subscribed yet make this
the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of clicking that bell and
selecting the option that says all
if you don't do that you're gonna miss a
lot of our videos even if you are
subscribed
it's just how youtube works and if you
like seeing actual visuals
on my video instead of just like me
talking over a blank screen
please show some love to my editor
dakota broski
he is also an anime youtuber so check
out his channel link
in the description finally this video
will of course contain
boku no hero manga spoilers we're
dealing with the latest events in the
story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as you will
recall at the end of the previous
chapter momo and the various class 1a
and 1b
students near the villain mansion
realized that the heroes couldn't stop
gigantomachia and so it would be up to
the students to try to take him down
because of his incredibly tough body
midnight
advised momo to create a sleeping agent
and put machia to sleep by forcing the
sleeping agent
into his mouth any attempt to pierce his
skin directly
appears to be pretty much impossible so
the mouth is the only way to go
so because they have to try to use
machia's mouth to inject
the sleeping agent the students have to
find a way to get close to makia's face
since he is so tall and since he is
moving quickly
the students decide to use juzo's
softening quirk to trap
machia inside a giant pit of mud which
will hopefully slow him down for long
enough to put some of the sleeping agent
into his mouth with the help of setsuna
whose creepy body part
detaching quirk enables her to keep an
eye on machia and determine his exact
route
while talking to juzo at the same time
juzo lays the trap
and all the students prepare themselves
for the inevitable showdown
but just before maki arrives the
students are informed that a bright blue
flame
is bursting out from makia's back this
means that dabi
must be riding on makia's back and if
dobby's there then it's likely that
other members of the league of villains
are up there as well
so not only do the students have to
worry about a gigantic
overpowered monster they also have to
worry about multiple
other powerful villains who are riding
on his back as makia approaches the
student's position
our girl mount lady is still desperately
hanging on to him in an attempt to slow
him down
even a little bit mount lady realizes
that machia is practically unstoppable
but to her credit she still keeps
fighting and she keeps trying to bring
him down
against all odds we absolutely have to
give props to mount lady for her courage
and perseverance
in this situation she is facing off
against an
indestructible and unstoppable mountain
of a villain
she has already been hit and thrown off
of him multiple times
and yet she keeps getting back up and
fighting on
for a pro hero who was first introduced
to us as a bit of a diva who seemed to
like
media attention and fame more than
actually getting her hands dirty
it's clear that mount lady is actually a
brave and honorable pro hero
i'm not sure if she was always this way
and the media just portrayed her as
something else
or if she has been developing over time
but regardless i have great respect for
her courage
and commitment as makia continues his
rapid advance
he steps right into the student's trap
he steps on the ground that was softened
by juzo
and falls into a giant pit the sudden
drop stops him in his tracks and also
rattles the other villains who were
riding on his back
the students rush into action they use
ibarashiozaki's vine quirk and other
quirks to pull makia's head
down meanwhile other students go on the
offensive against the villains on
makia's back
in an attempt to prevent them from
interfering with the mission to sedate
makia dobby uses his flames to keep the
students back
and mr compress is using his marbles to
launch a bunch of debris
at the heroes but there are a lot of
students taking part in this attack and
they are demonstrating some impressive
teamwork
for the moment it looks like the
students have the advantage
giro kaminari rei koyanagi and others
are keeping the villains on machias back
busy
and at least thus far their strategy
definitely appears to be working
as far as makia goes even though he is
currently trapped inside the pit he
isn't giving up
as the students attempt to force him to
ingest the sleeping agent
makia uses his breath to blow a bunch of
students away
his breath turns out to be like a
powerful hurricane and this
foils the student's plans to sedate him
at least for the time
being once the students are forced to
fall back
dobby turns up the heat and he uses his
flames to keep the students from getting
closer to machia
dobby notes that machia has multiple
different
overpowered quirks including the ability
to convert energy during a battle
into an increase in body size a quirk
that blocks out pain
and other highly useful quirks
machia was designed to be the perfect
bodyguard for all for one
and now for shigaraki and in that sense
makia is kind of like a nomu or rather
he is something between a normal person
and a nomu
just like the new shigaraki clearly
makia has been the subject of various
experiments and procedures
and he has been injected with multiple
quirks by ujico he is also
incredibly loyal to his master and he is
willing to follow
any order given to him but at the same
time
makia doesn't look like a conventional
nomu so the procedure that he underwent
is likely similar to shigaraki's
procedure
machia was made stronger and he was
injected with multiple quirks without
being transformed into a full-fledged
nomu
but he follows his master's orders very
closely
and he usually refuses to act at all
unless explicitly ordered to by someone
whom he acknowledges
as his master this part of the story is
very interesting to me personally
because i wonder whether shigaraki's new
procedure had some hidden element
to it i talked about this before but we
know from previous chapters that a part
of all for one's
own consciousness and personality is now
inside of shigaraki
and at times that second personality has
kind of taken over at least for a moment
like the time shigaraki referred to the
original user one for all as his brother
despite the fact that shigaraki himself
doesn't have a brother
he is of course the brother of one for
all not shigaraki
so far from what we've seen shigaraki
has been resisting this
influence from all for one and he is
determined to remain
in control of his own body but all of
this stuff about machia having multiple
quirks and also being subject to
procedures
has me wondering is it possible that all
for one's plans for shigaraki
are more manipulative than we thought is
it possible that ujico's procedure
not only made shigaraki much stronger
but also made him more vulnerable to
being controlled
by all for one just like machia is
incredibly strong
but completely subservient to his master
it's fair to assume that makia and
shigaraki
underwent a similar type of procedure so
who knows
maybe all for one really does want the
best for shigaraki
and the only purpose of the procedure
was to make shigaraki stronger
but maybe there's more to it perhaps
that aspect of all for one's
consciousness that is now inside of
shigeraki
will continue to get stronger until
shigaraki becomes as
obedient and prone to manipulation as
machia
that's all speculation at this point but
i am very curious to see
where this goes but back to the story
the students reveal that they placed
explosives at the bottom of the mud pit
and by activating those explosives they
can force machia to sink
even deeper so as makia tries to stand
up
and break free of the pit the students
activate the explosives and machia does
end up sinking deeper
which buys the students some more time
the spinner wonders why machia doesn't
just
tunnel underground since he is
apparently capable of doing this
and this would be much faster since he
wouldn't have to deal with any heroes or
hero students
but mr compress answers that the rest of
them who are on his back
would not be able to survive a
subterranean journey
so it seems that makia is avoiding going
underground because he was ordered by
shigaraki to deliver the league of
villains
safely to jakku personally i was pretty
surprised to learn that machia is
apparently able to just tunnel
underground like a gigantic version of
bug's bunny
but if what spinner said is true then
this is yet more proof of just how
versatile and op
machia is as a villain this guy
and the new shigaraki in the same place
at the same time
would be too much for the heroes to
handle that could honestly be game over
at this point so the heroes better do
their very best to avoid
this worst case scenario as makia
continues to struggle to get out of the
pit
our girl mount lady shows up yet again
she jumps on makia from behind grabs his
face
and does her best to force his mouth
open
the students couldn't force the sleeping
agent into makia's mouth
while he was keeping it closed but now
with mount lady yanking his mouth open
the students have a chance mina coats
her entire body with acid
using her acid man technique and she
jumps
right into dobby's flames she is
determined to get close enough to
makia's face to throw the sleeping agent
into his mouth she is using the acid
coating to protect herself
from the flames as she attempts to reach
makia's mouth
and if she succeeds the biggest threat
to the heroes
other than shigaraki himself might
actually be neutralized
we wish you the best of luck mina
however at this point we don't know
if mina actually succeeds at least not
yet
because this is the exact moment that
the chapter ends
overall this chapter further emphasized
just how opie
gigantomachia really is and how
important it is to stop him from meeting
up
with shigaraki at this point i honestly
can't think of any way that the heroes
could take on both shigaraki and
gigantomachia
if they were to join forces at the same
place at the same time
not to mention all the other overpowered
villains like dobby who are also along
for the ride unless the students can
really stop makia
right here and now this war arc could
turn into a total bloodbath that could
easily engulf
all of japan with gigantomaki and
shigaraki working together
entire cities would be destroyed the
villains would probably take over large
chunks of the country
and the heroes could actually end up
taking a massive l
at the end of this arc this is not
something that i ever would have
expected prior to this arc but with
everything that's been going on lately
it really does seem like horikoshi is
preparing to change
the entire dynamic of the mha world
it seems like the hero society is
crumbling and the villains might
actually score
some real serious w's before the
conclusion of this
arc so will mina or any other student
succeed
in taking machia out and if so
will the other villains like dabi manage
to get to jakku
even without machia personally i think
dobby will definitely make it there
because he needs to have that big
showdown with endeavor and
finally reveal his true identity that is
my opinion at least but we'll have to
wait and see
let me know what you guys think what do
you think about makia's power
the fact that he has multiple quirks and
do you believe that he
underwent a similar procedure to the one
that shigaraki just went through
if so do you think that shigaraki might
now be more prone to being manipulated
by all for one
as a result of this procedure could
shigaraki become an obedient servant of
all for one just like makia
without even realizing it or is
shigaraki's transformation
fundamentally different from machias
definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more boku no hero content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications remember that you
really have to go through the trouble of
clicking that bell and then selecting
the option that says all
if you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a lot of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime upper patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thanks to all of our the one
tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including
ingrata alolan adam the world steelers
acquired respect pate heffa jonathan
king
brandon aviles papa smurf the school bus
king riser emperor otaku ricardo
martinez
thomas jones kin mano michael hyde and
jaden the vector and i can't forget all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh nothing but a
fan
jason wilson kings eldris and anatoly
kazotsky
on hell cruise cricket xp joe stanton
very gucci
alicia octa jessica kayla fond hinokami
and water
bonnie parks zodiac 12 rathune de ora
kraken
arles and deadly saint if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you please consider supporting
us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you